when you sit back and you think about
someone
you know picking this album up and
listening to it from 1 to 36. what do
you hope that they get from it how do
you hope that it affects someone
listening
yeah I mean you know I started the album
was born with a beer in my hand and you
know that's just a song about the family
you're born into and the the good the
bad the terrible the awesomeness and all
that you know that happens after that
um I guess that song would be like if I
if I were to kept if I did keep a
journal that's probably what it would
say some days
um and then you know we ended it with
diamond man and that's just a song that
kind of you know hits on the idea that
someone or something you know gave you a
reason to keep living I mean I was never
like thinking I was gonna die or
anything but it's just it's geared
towards my son you know
um it gave me a huge reason to live and
a huge reason to live in a better way
and then everything in between you know
man it's just you know my my life over
the last couple years and and uh what it
what it's meant to me and you know
hopefully everyone can relate I think uh
everybody kind of it's been a weird time
in the world for for the last you know
five years and hopefully this song kind
of this this album brings some you know
some peace some some Joy some sadness
whatever it is that you're looking for I
think it's got a little bit of a little
bit of everything so I can't wait for
people to hear it a lot of these songs
of course sound really personal uh the
new single thought you should know I
think is like a great example of
personal reflection overcoming struggles
moving forward
um has your mom listened to it yet like
what does she think yeah I sent it to
her you know the the day or the day
after that we wrote it we uh
we didn't do like a demo I just had a
just a guitar and my cell phone and you
know put a voice memo up and uh I sent
it to her after we wrote it and she's
been hearing it for a long time but I
think she I think I know she appreciated
it and you know I put it out on Mother's
Day and in honor of her and
um yeah it's a the more personal special
songs of of my life
um
it's kind of like amazing to say that
Miranda Lambert is someone that you
could just kind of like call up right I
mean is that the case can you just call
it Miranda Lambert be like hey now I
can't now I can
um at that point at that point actually
that was the first time that I'd written
with Miranda
um
so I had had the idea for the song and I
came in with a a verse in course I think
and I was originally going to write with
Nicole Galleon that day and because I
wanted a I don't know a woman's
perspective you know for that song and
um so Nicole was like do you care if if
Miranda comes and writes no no of course
not you know that would be awesome so to
have two of the of the best female
Riders on you know in the world on that
song what really really helped me
complete it and and make it exactly what
I what I wanted to and you know they
they gave me some perspective that I
that I wouldn't have had you know on my
own so yeah but now I you know we wrote
like three four songs that day and you
know me and me and Miranda I got pretty
close after that and you know I look
forward to hopefully doing some more
things with her in the future
what's it like not able to say that
you've been working with like personal
Heroes of yours man Lambert you got Eric
Church on this one as well yeah it's uh
it's pretty mind-blowing man I mean you
know
um during The Outsiders tour I believe
it was 2014. that was the first concert
I ever went to is in Knoxville Thompson
Bowling Arena
um I was 21 years old and I was you know
just
just blown away I'd already become I was
already a huge
just you know just because of the his
style of writing his style of music I
just fell in love with with everything
that he did and once I saw him in
concert you know that kind of just
ignited a real a real fire in me that
you know maybe I could be like that one
day
um and then you know I had a full circle
moment last year playing a stadium with
him and and Minneapolis so that was uh
pretty surreal
um you know going from seat whatever on
the side of the stage to being on the
stage you know playing a show with him
and then being able to to have a song
with him you know me and him have grown
really really tight we talk you know
almost every day and
um yeah man I hit him up and was just
like hey I think this song would be
perfect for us and he said man I'm game
to do whatever so he came in and you
know it's that day in the studio with
him was one that you know I'll never
forget so it's uh it's been really
really cool to have him as as a friend
as a mentor and and just as a
collaborator
I think that having uh someone like Eric
Church is a collaborator
has helped you not just grow in terms of
like your Artistry but as an artist
dealing with everything that an artist
deals with when they got to go on tour
with your personal life I mean someone
who's had experience coming into your
life that you can you know like you said
he can mentor you yeah no doubt I mean
he you know he's got
um a lot of experience he's someone that
that I can go to with whether it's music
business questions
you know you know how to uh he's got a
lot of songs at this point I'm I'm
starting to have a lot of songs hey how
did you go about putting your set list
together how did you do this how did you
do that you know just um just all kinds
of things that you wouldn't necessarily
think about at the beginning of your
career but once you get into once you
get into the thick of it you know it's
nice to have someone that that's been
there already and someone that you trust
and and appreciate and you know look up
to so yeah he's definitely been there
for me in a lot of ways and I'm sure you
know he'll continue to be and I hope I
can you know be that for some young
artist one day do you ever think about
one day that in 10 20 30 years people
will be looking at your music the exact
same way
yeah I mean you know I haven't really
thought about it in that in that way
um I I guess it's a possibility you know
and I I think that's that's pretty
awesome but I've never I've never taken
those two and compared them like that
but that would be awesome I would love
to to see that happen you know I just
try to make music I love and if somebody
you know appreciates it and cares about
it that much 10 20 years 30 years 40
years down the road that would be that
would be an honor for sure
I mean one thing at a time right yeah
you know that's that's like the kind of
piece of advice that a parent gives you
right like my mom would say that to me
like one thing at a time the the photo
for the album cover that's on your
grandmother's porch right yeah my great
grandmother actually her name her name
was mamaw boots is what we called her
and she just uh she played a huge impact
in my life especially at an early age
and you know she lived to be 91 so I got
to spend a lot of time with her even as
an adult you know I was a young adult
and uh yeah she just meant a whole lot
to me and I had a lot of fond memories
at that house and you know I just kind
of wanted to to show my respect and my
love for her by by dedicating the cover
to her so I was glad that we got to get
a get a picture I liked and uh you know
that that looked good and I thought it
was appropriate for for this album
is that a thing that she would say take
it one thing at a time yeah I think I
think that's probably something she'd
say she'd uh she'd definitely be proud
of me you know she used to I was uh I
was always the you know the rowdiest kid
she had to chase me around the yard a
little bit more than she did all the
other kids but I also like to think she
had a had a soft spot for me as well so
yeah she she uh I think that's
definitely something she would say at
this point you know whenever she
whenever she passed I was kind of I was
getting started in the music but you
know not anywhere near what you know
what it's become now so yeah I think she
probably tell me to slow down a little
bit and you know if I needed to
do you see that same sort of like Rowdy
kind of running around rambunctiousness
in your son
yeah no doubt I'm starting to especially
here lately he's he's uh he's he's
getting a lot more personality you know
he's two and a half now so he's starting
to get into everything and he knows you
know when I tell him no he's gonna push
me as far as he possibly can
to try to get away with it you know but
it's uh I'm glad he's that way I I was I
hoped he was going to be that way so
he's uh you know it's it's uh it's
different for me you know it's like I
don't know exactly how to I'm just
learning to be a parent as well so we're
just learning each other over you know
over the couple years and I look forward
to getting him not to know him even more
the album sounds good you seem like
you're in a good place how are you
feeling going into this I guess sort of
like era of your career in your work now
yeah
um you know after the tour last year I
was a little bit ready for a break I got
a couple weeks and then we got into the
studio and you know I was kind of
concerned maybe I wouldn't be ready and
you know maybe I needed a little bit
more time but something you know about a
month ago whatever I started just woke
up one day and I was like hey I'm ready
to go so I'm feeling good
um I'm really excited about it obviously
you know it's a we're at we're at places
and and playing these venues that I
never even dreamed that we'd be
headlining you know so it's a huge
blessing I gotta I got a a great crew my
band's awesome I've had you know the
majority of my band with me since since
day one you know moved with me to
Nashville so it's cool to to have that
kind of Brotherhood and that kind of
that kind of you know camaraderie that
you can look back on the days in the in
the white you know Astro van or whatever
it was that we took you know back in
2015 2016. it's cool to to think about
those things and then see where we're at
now and it's uh I'm really looking
forward to it man I'm in a great place I
think everybody seems to be in a great
place and we're headed for uh for a big
time year now you're heading on this
worldwide tour in a couple of weeks
you're going to be coming to Canada at
the end of the summer cleaning tickets
sold out three back-to-back shows in
Toronto what can uh your Canadian fans
expect from this tour yeah I mean I'm
still I'm still working you know I just
got through with the album so I'm I'm in
the middle of I'm not in the middle I'm
about to get ready for rehearsals right
now you know like I was talking about
earlier trying to figure out what my
what my set lists are going to be all
that kind of stuff but you know when we
get to play three different nights in a
row I probably I'll probably do a little
bit of a different show each night but
I'm going all out on production I'm
going all out on on
um everything man this is going to be
the you know the most
time and preparation that I've had to
get ready for a tour
um the most the biggest crude the
biggest everything you know this is I'm
going all out so I think everybody
should you know if that's what they're
if that's what you're looking for it's
going it's definitely going to be a
production it's going to be a show and
obviously the music is the most
important and we do our best to to sound
great every night and I give my my all
every single night so I'm uh I'm looking
forward to it I've been to Canada before
I know what to expect there there's some
of the rowdiest greatest fans that I've
ever played for